[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission du 7-8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici lé
titre de ce vendredi de juin ils étaient
plus de 500 à participer à la 10ème
édition du trophée des entreprises entre
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et l'île de
loisirs les équipes et collègues ont dû
notamment participer à une course
d'orientation du course à pied ou encore
un relais vtt jean frédéric poisson est
notre invité fil rouge pour cette
émission le président du parti
chrétien-démocrate et député sortant sur
la 10e circonscription que nous
évoquerons avec lui à la dernière ligne
droite de la campagne son duel annoncé
avec aurore bergé la candidate de la
république en marche
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale nous reviendrons sur l'avenue à
versailles du président russe vladimir
poutine ou encore la ville de montigny
le bretonneux qui a décroché le label de
l'unicef nouveau label ville ville amie
des enfants
le trophée est des entreprises le rendez
vous sports et collègue était organisée
ce jeudi en fin d'après midi sur l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
pour sa dixième édition le départ était
donné depuis le vélodrome nationale au
total cinq cent quarante compétiteurs
répartis par équipes de trois se sont
affrontés pour réussir à passer les
épreuves les sportifs devaient combiner
performance esprit d'équipé
retour sur cet événement avec michael et
demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
dix ans que cela dure comme chaque année
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines a été le théâtre ce jeudi
premier jour du trophée des entreprises
l'objectif annoncé par les organisateurs
est de tisser des liens entre les
sociétés à travers une compétition
amicale qui se dispute par équipe de
trois
on a vu l'évolution là avec cette
dixième édition on est passé de 20
équipes la première année à 180 et on a
refusé encore une quasiment 25 l'équipe
au moment de la clôture des inscriptions
selon les 540 participants venus de 64
entreprises la compétition arrive à
créer un esprit d'équipé
c'est la société on n'est pas tout seul
si si c'est vraiment de la solidarité et
par rapport au travail aussi ça
contribue à former des liens se
raccrocher à se rapprocher de certaines
sociétés qui perd connaissance et des
liens et pourquoi pas venir collaborer
on sait qu'en pour renforcer encore plus
cette cohésion d'équipé un tracé
spécialité conçu au programme une course
à pied du vtt une course d'orientation
les sportifs ont dû également dompter
les vagues sur une épreuve de radeaux de
500 mètres pour éviter de boire la tasse
les concurrents dû se serrer les coudes
sur l'épreuve de radeau ils doivent
s'organiser ils ont de payet arado et
l'objectif c'est traverser pour arriver
au centre de voile et bien évidemment
pas de finir maintenant la main au
niveau de l'arche d'arrivée au sein du
vélodrome
après l'effort le réconfort tous les
compétiteurs se sont retrouvés après la
course pour partie
un afterwork l'occasion de créer une
nouvelle fois du lien social entre
collègues dans le reste de l'actualité
locale ce matin et organisait la
cérémonie de remise du permis internet
en salle de conseil municipal d'el en
cours pour les enfants
pour cette deuxième édition la ville
proposait à plus de 180 élèves de cm1 et
cm2 de passer ce certificat
encadrés par les agents de la police
municipale le but était de prévenir les
échos liés aux risques d'internet eux
ont normalement le vrai permis les
conducteurs vont devoir s'armer de
patience sur la route en ce week-end de
la pentecôte notamment lundi pour les
retours bison futé prévoit orange sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france et
notamment au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines des douze
heures et ce jusqu'à minuit patience
donc sur la route si vous avez eu la
chance aussi de partir en week-end
c'est le cinquième rendez vous depuis
son lancement l'an passé le conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
public interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine a fait un premier bilan
de son activité avec la mise en place de
services interdépartementaux le
lancement de l'aménageur public comme un
site alios avant la fusion effective des
départements qui sera d'ailleurs
demander prochainement au gouvernement
écouter pierre bédier et patrick
devedjian
les présidents des deux collectivités au
micro de nicolas landry elle avance de
plus en plus vite au point que
on a envie de passer le seuil critique
il ne vous a pas échappé qu'il y avait
des élections qu'il y avait un nouveau
président de la république que l'actuel
gouvernement était plutôt un
gouvernement de transition donc tout ça
crée quelques incertitudes sur le
calendrier mais la détermination des
deux présidents et je pense des deux
assemblées reste très forte
on va justement abordé ce thème du
rapprochement et de la fusion entre les
deux départements avec notre invité du
jour jean frédéric poisson dont soir
bonsoir
vous êtes député de la 10e
circonscription président du parti
chrétien-démocrate vous êtes candidat
sortant aussi pour les élections
législatives
quel est votre regard en qualité de
député sur ce rapprochement c'est que
beaucoup de conseillers départementaux
et élus locaux du sud yvelines sont
contre
c'est votre cas raymond cas aussi j'ai
lorsque j'étais président de la
communauté d'agglomération en oui les
territoires je me suis plus depuis le 31
décembre dernier
j'ai demandé au conseil communautaire de
voter une motion pour nous opposer à
cette fusion nous pensons que la
ruralité n'a pas grand chose à y gagner
nous ne comprenons pas très bien les
objectifs pour lesquels cette fusion est
envisagée ne voyons pas très bien ce que
nous pourrons nous en tirer comme et des
arguments économiques
oui mais ça je suis pas insensible aux
arguments économiques nous on
développement économique aussi dans la
zone rurale mais nous craignons beaucoup
que le centre de décision de s'éloigne
un peu davantage de nous et que
du fait qu'il est déjà difficile de se
faire entendre quand on est dans la zone
rurale ce soit encore plus compliqué
j'ajoute que la perspective d'avoir une
métropole de paris qui absorberait
purement et simplement l'ensemble des
départements de la petite couronne
ne nous permet pas de savoir si en
fusionnant les yvelines avec les eaux
seine
on ferait entrer les yvelines dans la
future métropole ou bien si on ferait
sortir les hauts-de-seine de la future
métropole donc si pour nous une
incertitude qui est extrêmement
difficile à appréhender
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines a plusieurs
fois rappelé qu'il s'opposerait à par
exemple une urbanisation du sud yvelines
est ce que vous le croyez quand il quand
il dit ça j'en faisais pas confiance
annoncé propos oullins long je crois
tout à fait je pense que président du
conseil départemental est attaché à
l'identité du département qu'il préside
s'est si je n'ai pas de mettre en cause
la parole du président bédié sur ce
sujet je ne sais pas s'il pourra
effectivement faire en sorte que ses
paroles soient suivies d'effets parce
que un grand ensemble de trois millions
d'habitants regarde de manière beaucoup
plus lointaine l'ensemble que nous
sommes à rambouillet territoire de 80000
que le département des yvelines actuel
de 1 million et demi de leurs gardes est
ce que le député actuels et éventuels
député futur de la circonscription a les
moyens par exemple de bloquer un tel
projet ou au moins de mettre la pression
sur les acteurs youtube bloqué il vous a
pas échappé qu'à l'assemblée nationale
nous sommes 577 donc comme dirait
l'autre à 1 contre 576 c'est difficile
d'encercler tout le monde donc c'est non
c'est sepsie pas c'est pas comme ça que
ça se pose
il ne faut jamais sous-estimer le
pouvoir l'influencé que peut avoir un
homme où quelques hommes qui sont
déterminés je crois que un certain
nombre de parlementaires sont déterminés
à ce que effectivement cette fusion si
elle devait se faire se passe dans des
conditions qui soient plus claires
meilleur est en tout cas pour l'instant
nous ne sommes pas encore là il faut je
le répète une décision du ministre de
l'intérieur pour entériner cette
opération ce qui viendra peut-être
et puisqu'on parle de réalité parfaite
transition pour parler des élections
législatives vous êtes donc candidat à
votre succession candidat investi par
les républicains pour lui dit c'est un
peu plus floue partagez vous allez
peut-être nous éclairer il ya eu des
tweets récemment notamment du président
de l'udps et christophe jean christophe
lagarde qui a déclaré qu'il ne vous
avais pas lui investi qu'en est-il
concrètement vous êtes candidat et
l'érudit heller moi je hais ce monsieur
lagarde à ses méthodes on les connaît
c'est pas un homme qui brille par la
qualité de sa parole donc je le laisse
dire ce qu'il veut il y à un
accord-cadre les républicains et de
délits qui est signée depuis le mois de
mars de manière définitive la 10e
circonscription des yvelines figurent
dans cet accord ça a été rappelé
d'ailleurs par philippe vigier qui est
mon voisin président du mobile il a
semblé lui fait partie de la commission
nationale d'investiture il a confirmé
devant vos collègues qu'effectivement
c'est moi qu'il y avait obtenu qu'il
avait obtenu le président le
secrétaire-général acoyer de la
confirmer par écrit fin mars
la réalité c'est que il y a là un
candidat unique qui s'était porté
candidat contre moi de manière
dissidentes se mélangent le suppléant de
madame berger et voilà moi je laisse lui
des irréguliers ces problèmes en interne
c'est moi qui ai d'investiture et des
issas souffre pas de contestation
d'ailleurs je suis désolé qu'on perde du
temps avec ça parce qu'alors on va vite
passer les ici dans le camp d'en face on
n'a que ça à faire valoir pour gagner
l'élection ça va passionner petite
question quand même sur votre rapport
aux républicains par exemple dans la
troisième circonscription des yvelines
il y a un candidat et l'eire qui
s'appelle philippe brillault qui est
opposé à un candidat nicolas tardy
joubert candidat divers droite qui a le
soutien officiel de votre personne
nationale est affiché sur sur ces tracts
et son affiche de campagne les ampoules
aussi le conseil il est conseiller
régional
d'île de france y est opposé à un
candidat ait l'air il a été élu sur la
liste madame pécresse
il y a toujours eu des candidats du
parti chrétien démocrate aux élections
législatives y en avait 100 9 en 2012
il y en a 120 cette année ça s'est
toujours parfaitement passé nous sommes
un parti associé aux républicains un
parti qui est indépendant nous avons des
accords électoraux de gouvernement dans
beaucoup d'endroits avec les
républicains ça se passe très bien ça
n'empêche pas que nous puissions
déployer le même notre propre identité
d'ailleurs j'observe que ce qui veut
dire que vous avez des exemples la
victoire le délit ou père lui des eaux
dont on parlait de brioni dont on
parlait tout à l'heure est également une
piste en a même situation
il ya des candidats qui ont investi
tueur commune il ya des quatre candidats
qui se présentent à côté des
républicains
on revient à la réalité un thème qui
vous est cher on le sait en qualité de
député ce que c'est le sujet clairement
principal pour cette 10e circonscription
le sujet principal une initiative c la
france y la particularité de l'élection
législative c'est que le député qui a
deux pieds doit avoir deux pieds à paris
et deux pieds dans sa circonscription
l'exercice est parfois un petit peu
difficile en attendant il faut faire à
la fois attention à ses électeurs chez
soi et puis au destin de la france à
paris si je peux dire les choses de
cette façon
c'est un c'est un sujet qui est la
ruralité pour nous très important parce
que c'est notre identité mais ce n'est
pas que la nôtre c'est 80% du territoire
national
c'est une quinzaine de millions
d'habitants dans toute la france alors
ça dépend de la de l'endroit où l'on
mètre seuil de population mais des
habitants qui participent activement au
maintien des activités sur toute la
surface du pays qui développe là où ils
sont et comme ils peuvent avec peu de
moyens une qualité de vie de l'emploi de
comment dire de la richesse des projets
innovants etc
et je pense que l'un des grands oubliés
une des grandes oubliées de la
présidentielle a été justement la
ruralité son développement et vous
souhaitez les soutenir avec cette idée
qui vient d'émerger pour récemment dans
le débat public la création d'une agence
nationale de rénovation en rural à quoi
servira concrètement cette agence de
quels moyens sera t-elle doté si
évidemment elle voit le jour
c'est une proposition de loi que nous
avons écrite conjointement avec mon
collègue philippe vigier président du
groupe idi de l'assemblée nationale
elle vise à assurer une équité de
traitement entre les territoires urbains
qui méritent d'être développées ou
rénovés et les territoires ruraux la
l'anru agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine existe depuis maintenant
plusieurs années voire au delà de 10 ans
elle est dotée tous les ans d'un budget
qui permet de rénover de l'habitat de
développer des programmes économiques
dans les banlieues ou les territoires
urbains qui sont défavorisés qui en a
besoin
nous voulons qu'il en soit de même pour
la ruralité autrement dit qu'à chaque
fois qu'un euros est versée pour rénover
la ville un euro soit versée pour
rénover la campagne c'est ça le principe
donc ses finances et bien sûr par budget
de l'état il faut placer cet agent sous
l'autorité du premier ministre pour que
des arbitrages politiques soient pris au
plus haut niveau et assuré les habitants
français des campagnes qu'ils seront
aussi bien traités que les habitants
forcé des villes c'est un sujet qui
intéresse vos collègues de l'assemblée
la ruralité vous vous sentez une
émulation sur ce type ce type d'idées ce
type à ce sujet ou alors on vient
il y a quand même vers certain nombre de
députés ruraux ça vous a pas échappé
premièrement et deuxièmement ce qui nous
motive avec mon cas négliger c'est que
on voit bien dans l'expression d'un
certain nombre d'électeurs quand ils
vont aux urnes et quand ils se portent
sur des parties qui ne sont pas des
partis de gouvernement
il y à l'expression d'une forme de dépit
d'une forme de sentiment d'abandon que
nous devons prendre en compte
moi je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
diabolisent qui que ce soit sur
l'échiquier politique je prends acte du
fait que dans beaucoup de villages dans
ma circonscription en bordure de la
région centre en particulier tous ceux
qui votent pour soi l'extrême gauche et
jean luc mélenchon seul front national
est bien en réalité ils votent pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux contre ce
sentiment d'abandon pour alerter leurs
représentants afin qu'on s'occupe d'eux
cette agence nationale de rénovation
sais pas si c'est pas une commission
pourrait pas être l'émission théodule
c'est par un groupe de travail
c'est pas une mission d'information
c'est une agence qui va devoir décider
de programmes d'investissement soutenir
les collectivités dans leurs actions
financées pour une grande partie
tous les travaux à réaliser et donc
améliorer le quotidien des citoyens dans
ces zones rurales de l'aude département
question d'un rapide jean frédéric
poisson réélu député de la 10e
circonscription votre à thilay la
moralisation de la vie publique la loi
sur la moralisation de la vie publique
proposée par françois bayrou
le premier texte dont vous aurez
probablement à débattre je voterai les
dispositions de moralisation de la vie
publique qui porte sur d'abord là
comment appelle-t-on salle
l'établissement d'une peine plancher
pour les élus qui auront été condamné il
en existe dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions sept peines planchers n'existe
pas il faut qu'elle soit dissuasive et
que ceux qui sont condamnés pour avoir
été indélicat dans l'exercice de leur
mandat soit vraiment très durement
sanctionnés et de manière exemplaire
deuxièmement je voterai les dispositions
qu'ils iront dans le sens de la volonté
de contrôler et de l'assurance des
citoyens que leurs représentants ne
peuvent pas faire n'importe quoi avec
les moyens qui sont qui nous sont
confiés
je m'étonne premièrement de la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle et pour
les associations et pour les communes
c'est là un mouvement de
recentralisation il est plus facile pour
une association d'aller demander une
subvention à son député
plutôt que d'aller là demandé au préfet
je ne vous fais pas de dessin donc ça
c'est une très mauvaise idée
la deuxième très mauvaise idée c'est la
suppression d'un corps de justice un des
principes fondateurs de la république
c'est la séparation entre le pouvoir
exécutif et l'autorité judiciaire placé
les ministres dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions sous l'autorité début c'est au
fond renoncer en partie à la séparation
des pouvoirs ça me paraît extrêmement
dangereux et puis enfin il ya des
dispositions qui reste à préciser sur
par exemple l'utilisation des
frais dont nous disposons pour louer nos
permanences ou exercer nos missions je
participerai à ça bien entendu et sans
aucune espèce de problème à partir du
moment où ce ne limite pas la liberté du
parlement pour revenir à l'élection
législative votre principal adversaire
il semblerait que c'est la candidate de
la république en marche
aurore bergé si on en croit les
résultats du second tour de la
présidentielle si on en croit voilà ces
résultats là merci comment vous jugez
pour l'instant cette campagne entre vous
et votre principal adversaire
d'un point de vue extérieur on a
l'impression qu'il ya une forme de
tension tout de même alimenté aussi par
les médias est-ce que c'est aussi votre
sentiment ou alors c'est exagéré on en
fait un combat pour pour les médiations
dans le jeu ne je ne suis pas je ne
combats personne je défend des idées
jeudi font un bilan une manière de me
placer au service de mes concitoyens
dans les yvelines comme en france et à
l'étranger
et voilà ce que je fais quand elle est
diamétralement opposée ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça c'est très vrai sale
est d'ailleurs sous deux rapports ça
laisse aux rapports des convictions qui
nous anime certainement et deuxièmement
c'est aussi l'opposition de style moi
j'ai bâti mon engagement politique sur
une fidélité à un territoire à une
famille politique est un ensemble de
conviction sur ces trois fidélité j'ai
passé 22 ans d'engagement personnel j'ai
gravi les marches exercé des
responsabilités face à l'alliance au
fait qu'elle est dans nicolas sarkozy
puis été ajoutés et puis et puis qu'elle
change de territoire à chaque élection
elle a participé à l'élaboration et la
construction d'un collectif anti macro
omet février elles demandent son
investiture en mars ou en avril
voilà chacun d'entre eux imaginent sa
carrière et chacun fait comme il veut
pour sa carrière politique
moi la mienne des frondes et sur la file
d'invités et l'enracinement vadam berger
fait d'autres choix ça la regarde que
vous soyez élu ou qu'elle soit élue
imaginons le 18 juin prochain il faut
quand même travailler quand on est
député avec les acteurs locaux les
politiques que vous pourriez travailler
avec les jeunes et je n'ai jamais cessé
de travailler avec les acteurs locaux
mais je ferais remarquer que madame
vergine n'est pas un acteur local de la
10e circonscription et les débuts de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint piat
à ibm maurepas oui elle est élue je
travaille d'abord mois avec le maire de
mortagne le maire de coignières est
régulièrement et je les connais bien je
les salue d'ailleurs dit si grégory des
restes et jean pierre sauvestre
maintenant si comme conseiller
communautaire de la casse qui madame
berger un dossier à soumettre qui
concerne maurepas et coignières je suis
évidemment parfaitement comme député
prêt à la recevoir pour parler de tout
ça jean frédéric poisson rester avec
nous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et cette semaine a été marquée par la
venue de vladimir poutine à versailles
invité par emmanuel macron le président
russe a inauguré l'exposition dédiée à
pierre le grand et qui célèbrent trois
siècles de liens diplomatiques entre les
deux pays vous voyez des images tout de
suite à l'écran les chefs d'état ont
également échangé pendant plus d'une
heure sur les dossiers internationaux
ils sont nombreux j'en fais dès que
poisson on connaît vos positions sur la
russie notamment qui se démarque de
beaucoup de politiques français
qu'avez vous pensé de cette visite vous
qui êtes pour un rééquilibrage de la
politique française à l'international
est-ce que ça va dans le bon sens ce
cette visite de la démerde poutine à
versailles il y a comme dans beaucoup de
deux rendez vous diplomatiques à la fois
un peu de brad faire un peu de mise en
scène et du dialogue
ce sont les trois composantes habituel
et trois ingrédients habituels d'une
visite diplomatique officielle monsieur
macron a voulu se placer dans une forme
de démarrage de rapport de force avec le
président russe
je trouve que c'est des victimes encore
une fois ça fait partie de son rôle et
de son statut est généralement non mais
sur sur le feu sur la forme et sur la
manière dont ça a été aménagé la manière
dont il m'a même pas qu'on rentre dans
sa fonction il n'y a pas beaucoup de
choses à dire enfin les choses se
passent comme elles doivent se passer à
l'image de ce que doit être le chef de
l'état français maintenant le point
central des relations avec la russie
c'est la levée des sanctions
j'ai voté comme mes collègues deux des
républicains à l'assemblée nationale il
ya un peu plus d'un an une résolution
qui a été adoptée d'ailleurs avec le
soutien à sa tombe le député socialiste
et tous les groupes une résolution pour
que les sanctions contre la russie soit
levé ses sanctions pénalisent d'abord
nos agriculteurs certainement pas
d'alliés mère poutine qui a bien sûr
trouver d'autres endroits pour acheter
des pommes des shoots rihanna mais russe
oui enfin je elle se porte mieux que ce
qu'on vit parce que là encore il ya
beaucoup de choses qui circulent et qui
sont pas tout à fait exacts mais en tout
cas nos agriculteurs sont les premiers
est sanctionné par
comment dire la mauvaise manière qu'on
fait à la russie il faut lever ses
sanctions et je pense que si on lève ses
sanctions sera davantage à même de
discuter correctement avec les russes
qu'ils sont nos alliés
les russes sont les alliés il n'y a pas
de doute là dessus ensuite espérer aux
discussions à ce que les français sont
leurs alliés alors pas toujours parce
que précisément la manière dont françois
hollande a humilié le président poutine
à plusieurs reprises a laissé beaucoup
de traces à moscou où il était il ya
quelques mois et j'ai discuté de ça avec
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la douma russe
qui ne l'a confirmé et deuxièmement
encore une fois l'attitude que nous
avons prises en adoptant ces sanctions à
l'égard de la russie sont très très mal
comprises dans ce pays une dernière
question une réponse rapide je sais que
ça va être difficile parce que le sujet
est majeur
c'est l'actualité la plus récente le
choix de donald trump de sortir de la
cap21 votre avis là-dessus
un échange en seniors un échec total du
g7 premièrement et deuxièmement bien la
nécessité en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive
parce que si la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes de renégocier trouver un
accord qui satisfasse tout le monde
c'est un sujet très important il faut
qu'il faut explorer n'a pas le choix on
n'a pas le choix
donc il va falloir trouver les voies et
moyens de le faire c'est un sujet trop
important pour qu'on s'arrête là et
alors pas vous ne parlez pas des
affaires ferrand et bayrou est cerné
c'est dommage parce que je trouve qu'au
moment où on entame la moralisation de
la vie publique d'avoir un ministre en
exercice qui est à moitié coupable de
quelque chose qui ressemble furieusement
au moins au moins à une énorme
maladresse teinté de rose avait
heureusement en lançant je maintiens que
cette affaire de cette affaire de
moralisation de la vie publique devient
d'une hypocrisie totale donc j'espère
bien que le premier ministre et le
président clarifieront la situation des
juifs est rentré vous recevra en plateau
à ouvrir les débats de la 10e
circonscription avec les expédier les
gens fêtent avec poisson est devenu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
candidat investi par les républicains et
lui dit aussi du coup l'option la 10e
circonscription des yvelines merci à vos
et puis du coup bonne copine bonne
dernière semaine de campagne
on enchaîne avec le reste de l'actualité
cette semaine et la mort soudaine du
maire de saint germain en laye et
emmanuel lamy ses obsèques avait lieu
hier plusieurs centaines de personnes se
sont rendus près de l'église saint
germain pour rendre un dernier hommage
au maire de la commune de nombreuses
personnalités politiques locales étaient
aussi présentes sur place sans
transition à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
financier son projet d'entreprise par le
financement participatif c'est désormais
possible l'agglomération a présenté
mardi sa nouvelle plateforme sky invest
les détails avec ce sujet de camille
lambert développement innovation
embauche les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines peuvent maintenant
faire appel au financement participatif
pour mener à bien leurs projets
particuliers ou professionnels
deviennent alors acteurs de l'économie
locale
les financeurs sont vous et moi si vous
avez 1000 5000
euros à placer plutôt que de le mettre
sur un livret a dont vous savez qu'il
vous rapportera pas grand chose vous
pouvez aller sur le site voir si un
projet vous séduit il ya deux outils
soient des prêts donc vous prêter sous
forme d'investissements soit vous
rentrez au capital et vous devenez
actionnaire de cette entreprise
le dispositif s'adresse aux entreprises
du territoire
immatriculée au registre du commerce et
des sociétés pour le mettre en place
la communauté d'agglomération a créé un
partenariat avec l'entreprise kiosque to
invest ça sera soit toutes les start up
m et toutes les structures corps et des
besoins de financement pour financer
leur développement leur croissance qui
auraient un besoin donc en fonds propres
entre 100000 euros et 2005 les seules
contraintes on va dire juridique c'est
que la société soit et ça ou ss ou en
mesure de le devenir et ensuite et
qu'elle ait réalisé un premier chiffre
d'affaires ou alors une première
première promesse de chiffre d'affaires
pour déposer votre projet ou allez les
découvrir
rendez vous sur le site de sky invest
depuis sa création il ya quelques mois
la plateforme a déjà recueilli trois
demandes de financement les projets sont
actuellement en cours de validation à
montigny le bretonneux la ville a
décroché en mars dernier le nouveau
label ville amie des enfants label
décerné par l'unicef france de documents
officiels a été signé ce mercredi à
l'occasion d une idée un événement de
sensibilisation sur les droits de
l'enfant la journée a mobilisé plus
d'une centaine de jeunes âgés de 3 à 10
ans à travers toute la ville un
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
c'est officiel montigny le bretonneux la
12e villes du département se voir
décerner le label ville amie des enfants
distinction accordée par l'unicef le
fonds des nations unies pour l'enfance
et deux parties ont signé la charte ce
mercredi 31 mai au sport du poirier
saint martin lee addy fiche spéciale à à
renseigner sur le handicap sur la façon
de vivre sur la santé sur l'éducation
dans le dossier de montigny je crois que
ce qui fait la différence ce qui fait
que on peut accepter montini comme ville
amie des enfants c'est qu'à travers ce
dossier on voit la solidarité que veut
exprimer la ville par rapport aux aux
enfants par rapport aux enfants de
toutes les races de toutes les cultures
j'irai enfin enfin la politique menée
par la ville de montigny en direction de
leur enfance et reconnu à son juste
niveau
on rappelle que nous
travaillons bien sur ce cd politique est
là depuis très très longtemps sur le
terrain ce partenariat va permettre de
réaliser des journées de sensibilisation
comme ce fut le cas avec les unis dès ce
mercredi
l'événement organisé par le conseil des
jeunes de la ville et l'unicef a permis
à travers des jeux et des panneaux
informatifs d'expliquer les droits des
enfants
l'enfant apprend à travers les jeux
l'enfant à travers apprend à travers le
fait d'être en bonne santé de savoir
avoir les notions d'hygiène nécessaires
l'importance de la vaccination pour
éviter les les maladies l'importance
d'aller à l'école pour apprendre mais
pour apprendre le devenir de deux des
nations de comment progresser dans la
vie on ne peut pas progresser sans
éducation
le label ville amie des enfants est
valable jusqu aux prochaines élections
municipales de 2020
montigny-le-bretonneux devra alors
constituer un dossier pour prolonger
l'aventuré avec l'unicef
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis retrouver tous nos
reportages sur notre site internet
internet ou l'application tv fil 78
points comme bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]